Chicago Cubs pitcher Marcus strowman
wants kids to learn the importance of
believing in themselves and that life
may have some strikeouts along the way
it does for all of us the MLB All-Star
has been striking out opponents for
nearly a decade now as part of the Blue
Jays the Mets and now the Cubbies he's
also a mental health Advocate especially
for kids strowman writes about it in his
new children's book it's called the grip
it is a fictionalized account of young
Marcus who struggles when trying out for
his local baseball team the grip is
published by an imprint of Simon and
Schuster which like CBS is part of
Paramount Global and first on CBS
mornings Marcus strowman joins us now
Marcus thank you for being here the book
is terrific and you are very excited for
it to be out I know why did you want to
get involved in writing books for kids
10 12 13 years old
man I've always seen myself as a as a
role model for the Youth and
I know how much kids these days are
going through especially with the social
media phase how much adversity today
kind of go through and I'm someone who's
been through that my whole life and I
just wanted to kind of put a book out to
help people navigate there's so much
wisdom in the book and I know some of it
comes from your real life coaching and
your parents there's one comment from
your mom in here about how there are
things you can control and things you
can't and the one thing you can control
is your preparation yeah and the rest
you just hope and pray did she really
say that to you yeah my mom is my rock
she's my best friend still to this day
as is my dad and
they kind of instilled that that belief
in me that if you put the work in if you
truly dedicate anything to what you want
to do in life you can accomplish it and
very thankful for kind of those mantras
and and lessons they taught me even
though your dad you write was very very
tough like at one point in your book you
said we had to practice every single day
in capital letters we still practices
every day basically they said it took a
week off in the off season I know but
Dad seemed to be very hard I bet you
didn't appreciate it then but how do you
look back on that now yeah like you said
it was a little hard in the moment but
I'm so appreciative my father now he
instilled the work ethic and confidence
in me that I feel like has allowed me to
separate myself yeah so I'm the biggest
believer in every morning getting up
training getting your work in and
everything starting your day yeah I also
thought it was interesting that you said
I like the book as well because part of
it is true but part of it is you wish
would have happened to you when you were
growing up there's a great scene with
your mom where she says you know Marcus
maybe we better get you a mental health
coach you're very stressed about making
the team that is the grip Society yeah
doing yourself as a failure absolutely
did you actually get a mental health
coach then I didn't but now in the last
few years I've had that I've had a
therapist I've had a mental health coach
I've had a mental coach for performance
that's something I wish my younger stuff
would have been open to and I feel that
young kids nowadays should have that
option to be able to get things off
their chest yes why did you think it was
important to include that especially
young young boys certainly young boys of
color you're supposed to be tough you're
supposed to be strong you're not
supposed to admit to any weakness yeah
just like you said an African-American
and especially African-American men I
feel like we're always supposed to
portray this masculine image and be
strong
and by holding a lot in we we kind of
put a lot of stress and anxiety on
ourselves so being able to talk to
someone having an outlet I think it's
huge it helps with not only performance
on the field but it just helps with your
whole calm in life if we don't address
it we end up losing grip on things
absolutely um you know when you first
came in the game it was different you
know guys in the locker room didn't talk
much I want you to take the viewer into
locker rooms now because I feel like
athletes are more open not just having
conversations with a therapist but open
with each other do you find yourself
having like a real conversations with
your teammates yeah absolutely I think
within a team you're gonna find you're
kind of people who really identify with
and those it kind of becomes your family
in a sense because we're around these
individuals so much so yeah you find
yourself I think it's becoming more open
to talk about hey I'm dealing with this
away from the fields or I'm feeling this
way when I'm on the mound how are you
getting through it right and you bounce
ideas off of each other and those are
essentially coping mechanisms that you
can use in your everyday life as well
that's good got a beautiful few notes to
your son Kai yeah
in the front here what are you hoping he
takes away from this book
just he gets to that point yeah yeah
um I just hope he has the calm and the
ability to get through anything which I
I feel like he will but life throws a
lot at you yeah and I'm just hoping he
has the ability to stay on an even Keel
and be able to battle any type of a
version so Daddy's always got you just
like my father always has my back no
matter what yeah you had two great
mantras at stuck out to me always
believe that you have a chance I think
that's really important dad says no one
can ever criticize you or make you feel
bad for trying your best true no
absolutely because at the end of the day
when you put in all this work and you
prepare it's like some things are out of
your control you can only go out there
and give your best effort so all right
Marcus strowman speaking of prepared if
you're a Cubs fan he says the Sinker is
working that's right if you're a reader
the grip is on sale today and he says
baseball's never boring
Sports illustrator said he's due for a
breakout season they know every season
breakout it's about to shine like them
diamonds in his mouth